خبر غير صار من ابل خصوصا الذين يخزنون
صورهم على ماي فوتوستريم ابل اعلنت ايقاف
امكانيه تخزين المستخدمين للصور على متن
الخدمه في سادس وعشرين من يونيو على ان
يتم ايقاف الخدمه المجانيه لحفظ الصور
بشكل نهائي في السادس والعشرين من يوليو
القادم دعت ابل المستخدمين الى ضروره
الاعتماد على خدمه تخزين الصور في اي
كلاود فوتوز كبديلا لخدمتها في ماي
فوتوسترين كما ان جميع الصور التي يحتفظ
او يحتفظ بها مستخدمه مايفوتوسترين سيتم
مزامنتها مع خدمه ايكلاود وستظل متاحه
لمده شهر من تاريخ السادس والعشرين من
يوليو بحيث يتمكن المستخدم خلال تلك
الفتره من نقل صوره المحفوظه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات